pour en parler nous sommes avec david
guiraud porte-parole jeunesse la france
insoumise bonsoir david guiraud merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés virginie
joron députée européenne rassemblement
national bonsoir à vous madame merci
d'être avec nous également
au moins 35 mille un manifestant
aujourd'hui des policiers des élus on en
reparlera évidemment mais tout d'abord
première question en virginie un jour on
pour vous il y aura un avant et un après
ce que c'est une manifestation pour rien
ou enfin le message va être entendu
selon vous déjà il n'y a pas un avant et
un après ça fait des années qu'il a ce
malaise aujourd'hui est une prise de
conscience de tous puisque effectivement
il avait plus de trente cinq mille
manifestants il y avait une
intersyndicale dont plusieurs syndicats
pour exprimer le même mot d'ordre donc
le malaise policier
effectivement le besoin de se faire
entendre parce qu'on le voit depuis des
mois et surtout ces dernières semaines
un emballement de la delà de la violence
envers les forces de l'ordre qui est
insupportable et évidemment nous étions
présents parce que c'est aussi un devoir
citoyen de rendre hommage à cette
profession qui est de plus en plus mal
traités
nous avons pas attendu effectivement ce
jour pour toujours soutenir cette
profession nous allons déjà l'an passé
proposé un plan pour complet de
propositions quarantaine de propositions
pour effectivement mettre en avant les
policiers leur donner plus de mariée en
matériel de la formation plus de moyens
en matière pénale aussi puisque
effectivement le problème c'est que ya
un sentiment d'impunité mais a même plus
ce sentiment il ya une impunité totale
et donc effectivement nous sommes là
avec eux depuis le début et demain
encore plus alors on a vu évidemment
beaucoup de politiques sur ce cortège
l'un d'entre eux brillé par son absence
la france insoumise votre parti david
guiraud virginie jour on nous parlait
d'un devoir citoyen
m aujourd'hui pourquoi vous vous avez
refusé d'être présent sur place la
france est soumise
bah écoutez c'est simple on nous avait
parlé à la base d'un hommage en général
un hommage pour des morts vous venez
avec des fleurs par un catalogue de
revendications
ensuite on nous a dit que c'était une
manifestation citoyenne j'ai pas vu de
citoyens d'ailleurs hésité qui avait que
des policiers des journalistes qui
étaient autorisés à entrer dans ce
rassemblement bon et ensuite j'ai
entendu les revendications des
organisations policières et ses
organisations policières de 10 quoi
c'est la faute de la justice que il n'y
a pas assez de fermeté qu'elle et du
laxisme judiciaire
tout ça ça puissions 1 je pense à un
désarroi réel des policiers c'est vrai
qu'il ya une souffrance c'est vrai qu'il
ya des moyens qui sont en berne
mais par contre je peux pas laisser dire
des choses fausses parce qu'il ya des
choses qui sont fausses
quand on nous dit qu un laxisme
judiciaire vous êtes quand même au
courant que les violences sur personne
dépositaire de l'autorité publique le
taux de réponse pénale c'est 95%
quand vous faites des violences sur des
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique vous avez 75% de condamnations
qui sont assorties d'une peine de prison
même quand il n'y a pas dit est et
l'interruption de travail donc pardon
mais il est où le laxisme là dedans
le taux de réponse pénale en 2016 ces 94
8 7% en 2008 18 aussi 2010 9 95%
c'est quoi ces du laxisme ça le
ministère de la justice lui même
il dit que les violences sur les
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique elles sont plus souvent l'objet
de deux procédures alternate son bref
moins souvent l'objet de procédures
alternatives que les autres peine 20%
d'un côté contre 40 % dans les autres
domaines
il ya de la comparution immédiate dont
on sait que la comparution immédiate
vous même bien plus souvent sur les
options judiciaires lourds à 22 % quand
il s'agit de deux délits sur les
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique contre 9 % pour les autres il
est où le laxisme
moi j'aimerais bien qu'on mais qu'on me
le dise je veux bien avant une
discussion mais sur des faits concrets
parce que là aujourd'hui il ya une
souffrance de tous les agents de l'état
ap les policiers d'ailleurs qui souffre
de manque d'effectifs jeu bien en parler
mais aussi de leurs missions qu'on leur
donne et moi je peux pas accepter qu'on
commence à discuter sur des suppositions
basé sur aucun argument concret juste en
instrumentalisant une souffrance ça
c'est pas honnête on va les dents
du débat dans quelques instants mais
mais mais avant tout sur la présence
politique parce que c'était quand même
l'un des des débats qui a émaillé ce
rassemblement entre la présence de
gérald darmanin et votre absence à vous
la france insoumise votre collègue jean
zen bardella très critique envers
d'ailleurs elle est fille qui nous a
expliqué que selon le numéro deux du rnd
roncq un jean luc mélenchon représente
une partie de la gauche qui a sombré
dans du jusqu'au boutisme séparatiste
virginie joron vous partager cette
opinion
oui c'est vraiment les absents mais en
même temps ça m'étonne pas puisque ils
ont un discours anti flics depuis le
début alors c'est facile d'annoncer des
chiffres mais en même temps ce qui
prouve une chose c'est que peut-être
vous annoncer les chiffres qui est un
pas de laxisme judiciaire
mais en attendant moins d'une semaine
vous avez tous les jours des ces divers
qui prouve que il ya un emballement de
la violence donc ce qui veut dire que la
réponse pénale n'est pas adapté donc il
ya déjà la réalité en prenant juste une
semaine de ses divers vous avez regardé
la semaine du 27 avril vous avez tous
les jours des attaques contre les forces
de l'anp un emballement de long le
voyais à plus de 6000 policiers blessés
en une année ça a doublé donc voilà il a
dû il ya du factuel vous voulez
d'ignorer et à côté de ça vous voulez
pas faire aller faire corps avec ceux
ses forces de l'ordre qui sont là pour
nous protéger
ça c'est quelque chose que vous vous
laisse entendre sans doute pas entendre
mais sont là pour protéger la nous
protéger tout citoyen quelles que soient
nos couleurs politiques et aussi
restaurer la paix et aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans un dans un chaos on le voit
tous les jours avec ces faits divers ils
sont là pour protéger et surtout
rétablir la paix sociale la paix partout
dans les banlieues partout dans les
villes et c'est un constat qui est qui
est effrayant et cette manifestation
elle est là pour dire attention
attention il faut prendre que les élus
tous les élus doivent abandonner pour
prendre conscience parce que c'est de
pire en pire et si aujourd'hui on
continue à se voiler la face
demain ça va être la guerre civile david
guiraud c'est vrai que
justice à c'était d'ailleurs l'un de vos
griefs envers cette manifestation la
justice a été prise pour cible les
dégâts d'un cran n'ont plus de limites
le problème de la justice de la police
et la justice c'est vrai qu'on entendait
des témoignages nous dire voilà on a à
peine fini de rédiger le pv que les
délais le pont sont déjà dehors est ce
que ça c'est une réalité
ça semble être le cas en tout cas sur le
terrain que vous m'aimiez à la france un
son mythe
non mais attendez sur le taux sur le
délai de réponse pénale ya un problème
mais parce que la justice manque de
moyens c'est pas de la faute des
magistrats
c'est que l'état avait investi la
justice mais j'aimerais revenir sur ce
que disait madame joueront madame joron
on dit attention demain ça va être la
guerre civile ça vous dérange pas la
guerre civile madame 1 qu'en 2019 êtes à
l'aise à damas en syrie en twittant qu'à
damas il faisait bon vivre le pays avec
la capitale sont au sein d'une guerre
civile sera pas l'air de trop vous
déranger ans ça a l'air d'aller
vous nous dites des chiffres regarder
typiquement la désinformation à laquelle
vous participez vous nous dites il ya
6000 agression de policiers
d'accord vous êtes au courant parmi les
6000 agression de policiers madame 70%
ces des accidents s'est défait
accidentelle c'est pas des agressions
donc pardon mais moi je veux bien
reconnaître payer des agressions sur les
possibles vous savez je vais même vous
dire il ya une légère augmentation
effectivement des agressions sur les
policiers dans le pays ya une
spécificité tristement française c'est
que les attentats terroristes visent
souvent plus les policiers en ce moment
que les civic ça c'est une réalité dont
il faut parler il ya du trafic de drogue
et du trafic de drogue qui en expansion
dans le pays s'est adressé une réalité
mais vous savez la france est soumise
après des propositions là dessus la
france me demande juste à ce qu'on voit
les choses autrement qu uniquement par
le biais sécuritaire parce que le biais
sécuritaire c'est quoi sur le trafic de
drogue c'est un million d'heures qu'on a
donné de travailler à la police en plus
bon quels sont les résultats
les gens consomment plus de cannabis
qu'avant ces 150 mille interpellations
par an à part mettre des policiers dans
l'embarras est ce que ça résout le
problème du trafic de drogue n'ont donc
on dit juste on veut changer la
politique et arrêter d'être dans le
délire sécuritaire pour une raison
simple c'est que d'une ça profite pas la
population mais surtout quand vous
pensez régler tous les problèmes de la
société uniquement les mettant sur
d'au-delà policiers des policiers eh ben
vous mettez les policiers en danger dans
l'embarras pourquoi parce que les
policiers voient
investis de missions qu'ils n'ont pas
affaire parce que les policiers sont pas
médecins ne sont pas prof
ils sont pas assistants sociaux ils sont
pas psychologue et que vu que l'état
reculé dans tous ces domaines c'est eux
souvent qui se retrouve à être appelés
pour des tâches parfois absurde parce
que des fois y'a pas de paul il n'y a
pas de médecins qui viennent dans les
quartiers alors on appelle des policiers
parce que des fois il ya des des choses
qui pourraient être réglés par des
médiateurs on appelle les policiers et
vous voyez le problème de la dérive
sécuritaire il est là il est dans le
fait que des gens pensent tout réglé
avec la police bas moi je les dirige la
firme j'ai pas peur de le dire ça
marchera pas y'a aucun pays où ça marche
est typiquement si on n'est pas les
rassemblements aujourd'hui mais c'est
pour une raison simple c'est qu'on
partage pas les revendications les
peines plancher on a connu ça on a
l'expérience en france des peines
planchers faudrait peut-être quand même
un jour faire le bilan de ce qu'on a
fait c'était la loi dati la loi dati on
a l'expérience de ce qui s'est passé
de 2007 à 2010 devinez quoi
les taux de récidive des gens qui ont
été jugés avec les peines plancher ils
ont augmenté
donc en fait la répression bat ça marche
pas à tous les cas voilà et donc ceux
qui disent ça sont taxée d'anti fiq pas
d'accord mais moi en attendant ce que je
constate c'est depuis que je suis gamin
j'entends toujours le même discours et
que la situation fait que s'aggraver
donc je le dis que ce soit aux arènes
qui est cohérent dans sa logique le r&d
cohérent darmanin je comprends un peu
moins le ps comprend - le parti
communiste français je comprends moi ça
j'avoue j'ai un peu honte même que des
gens se soit fourvoyé là dedans mais je
le dis juste qu'ils aient un débat de
société
est-ce que sécuritaire ça marche au-delà
des questions idéologiques et quand vous
regardez les chiffres pour la sécurité
est ce que ça marche
écoutez - déjà quand j'entends ça je me
dis qu'on vit pas sur la même planète
monsieur parce que vous gêne vous aviez
donc à une autre vision moi jeune moins
jeune je voulais rentrer dans la police
veut faire des ss police sécurité 196 et
j'ai fait un mois dans un commissariat
et j'ai vu déjà le métier le malaise et
les difficultés qu'ils avaient déjà à
exercer leur métier et vous vous niez
donc en fait pour vous le problème c'est
que c'est donc les dealers donc si les
pâtes d'inertie et pas de drogue y
aurait pas donc de devoir livrer pas
qu'il y aurait pas d
livré dans un monde merveilleux parce
que effectivement le problème donc on a
instauré la répression de la droite et
hot finalement délivre donc en fait pour
vous il faut il faut pas de délit il
faut pas de policier et on est dans un
monde de bisounours mais pardon mais ce
n'est pas la réalité
si c'est un peu ce que nous dit en fait
il faut dépénaliser il faut dépénaliser
pour pas donc mais des forces de l'ordre
dans dance est dans cette perspective
d'arrêter des dealers et du coup
finalement on miserait légèrement de
merveilleux moi je suis désolé et aussi
et la population aujourd'hui vie cette
insécurité je suis désolé peut-être vous
vous ne la vivait pas et tant mieux pour
vous mais là la majorité des français
sont son se sentent agressés quelques
dents tout dans tous les mémos ruralité
paris est évidemment dans certains
quartiers plus que d'autres mais même
dans la ruralité
donc voilà je pense qu'on vit pas sur la
même planète tant mieux pour vous
apparemment tout se passe bien chez vous
mais je pense que c'est pas la majorité
des français qui vivent la même chose
que oui bah alors madame pardon excusez
moi je me suis créé pour elle et ses
avocats sur une mine aux gets que la
seine-saint-denis un pardon mais juste
moi je veux vous dire une chose ya pa
n'ya pas non plus pas que le trafic de
drogue j'ai pas dit ça je ne sais pas
quelle position vous n'affrontez je vous
dis juste que par contre on veut changer
radicalement des politiques publiques en
termes d' approche de la criminalité et
que moi j'ai pas de problème à parler de
2,2 d'éradication de la délinquance
c'est pas un problème et ça passe pas
que par le trafic de drogue mais par
contre ils sont quand même prendre en
compte cette dimension là parce qu'il ya
le trafic d armes derrière quand on
parle de police de proximité quand on
parle de renfort de deux contrôles des
douanes par exemple le douanier d'astous
passé avec l'union européenne
c'est pas normal je suis désolé voilà
mais on est pour des approches concrètes
et quand on parle de sécurité je vous
dis juste que je ne veux pas c'est ce
délire sécuritaire parce qu'il lance
quanta liste des souffrances réelles
mais dans ce cas là parlons des
souffrances réelles des policiers par
exemple qui sont liées au nombre de
mains au manque d'équipement
ça c'est des problèmes concrets si des
policiers manifestent sud elle avait
alors justement à ce sujet là le
gouvernement il répond typiquement à ces
questions de demande de moyens je vous
propose d'écouter le porte parole du
gouvernement gabriel
attal nous sommes du côté des forces de
l'ordre
quand beaucoup ne se paie que des
formules et des coups de menton
nous soutenons les forces de l'ordre en
mots mais aussi en actes nous sommes
présents en augmentant les salaires des
gardiens est dégradée 200 euros nets par
mois renforçant la formation des
policiers en payant des millions
d'heures supplémentaires en renouvelant
la moitié des véhicules et en rénovant
rénovant les commissariats et brigades
de gendarmerie le gouvernement est il
présent on actes et pas seulement en
mots virginie joron comme l'affirment
gabriel est allé comme vous voulez
l'attesté la présence de gérald darmanin
sur le terrain aujourd'hui encore une
fois c'est bien mais pourquoi maintenant
ça fait des années que nous sommes dans
cette situation ça fait des années et
des années que les forces de l'ordre
réclame des moyens
pourquoi attendre maintenant à quelques
mois des échéances électorales dont
c'est pour moi de la communication
j'espère effectivement que des moyens
vont être déployés mais encore une fois
il faut être cohérente c'est tout c'est
tout un plan qu'il faut mettre en place
dans plus de quarante propositions
effectivement de la formation des moyens
matériels un suivi d une cellule
spécifique aussi parce qu'il ya un taux
de 2 recrudescence de du suicide qui est
inacceptable
et évidemment un problème au niveau
pénal où il ya quand même malgré les
chiffres de monsieur giraud il y a quand
même on le voit bien
un laxisme à ce niveau j'ai quelques
faits divers ou 1 où il ya eu une
attaque la semaine dernière à bagnolet
sur 20 personnes une seule personne a
été interpellée et c'est comme ça tous
les jours il est même cet après-midi
quand j'étais dans la manifestation j'ai
donc converser avec un policier il me
disait de toute façon les en un mot
d'ordre aujourd'hui ne plus intervenir
donc voilà on est dans cette situation
qui est gravissime il y a un début de
réponse mais elle est trop tard et il
faut un plan cohérent et seul mou depuis
des années nous sommes nous avons nous
avons réfléchi sur ce sujet on
appliquait en propositions en matière de
police on applique la recomposition
matière de justice donc on a un plan
cohérent et nous sommes prêts à soutenir
cette profession et surtout leur donner
les moyens dont ils ont besoin david01
un bon début mai mais c'est trop tard
audi
virginie joron sur l'action du
gouvernement votre avis c'est le mot de
la fin rapidement s'il vous plaît non
rien ne va rénova moi je combats cette
logique sécuritaire qui d'ailleurs
effectivement créé des suicides c'est un
vrai sujet des suicides dans la police
plus d'ailleurs que les policiers qui
meurt en exercice en suicides dans la
police la france est soumise à proposer
une commission denquête à l'assemblée
pour savoir pourquoi les policiers
suicider qu'est ce qui se passait
comment résoudre le problème ça a été
refusé par en marche et sur tous les
aspects de sécurité
on veut nous faire croire que augmenter
la répression ça marche mais déjà c'est
le gouvernement par exemple sur la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
qui était censée être la première cause
quand même du quinquennat
une des grandes causes du quinquennat eh
ben il n'a pas été à la hauteur il n'a
pas débloqué des fonds suffisants sur la
justice moi je veux bien
les policiers disent d'eux c'est de la
faute de la justice mais la justice elle
même demande à pouvoir bien faire son
métier
mais quand vous n'avez pas de griffier
dans les tribunaux pas de place pas de
créneaux horaires comment vous faites
vous pouvez pas et ça c'est des choses
concrètes
madame jour on se base sur des faits
divers écoutez si vous faites une
politique publique basée sur des faits
divers on encourageait les amis moi je
me base sur les chiffres du ministère de
la justice sur les chiffres de
l'observatoire national de la
délinquance et des réponses pénales
ça c'est de voir moi je ne sais pas il
ya un monde entre être un peu sérieux en
fait dans ce qu'on fait white terrier
qu'elle sorte du chapeau les
statistiques 1 elles sortent bien
quelque part à la statistique à mes fans
et 57,2 dit à l'ats soir ce fut
effectivement fait savez vous savez
madame avec les faits divers c'est tout
le problème
moi il y en a qui s est agacé ce qui
alimente les statistiques à daegu
merci à trader de keriolet resserré en
habillant daniela la fin ah oui les
filles spare parts dont il ya des morts
tous les jours tous les jours on
pourrait les les journaux télévisés
pourrait se transformer en rubrique
nécrologique si on le voulait est ce
qu'on ferait avancer c'est sain c'est
dit merci et chacun jugera et on a
gonflé merci david guiraud mercier
bergeron d'avoir été avec nous en direct
à 1 sur rt france